my girl has love in her heart and snow  in her eyes and pepper in her life every  birthday kiddo I like many was first  introduced to you from alias as Sydney  Barstow does peppermint have any type of  action callbacks to your beginnings very  much so it's there's a lot of action and  this woman is more of just a  single-minded she has a job to do and  she's gonna get it done I think Sydney  never really wanted to hurt anyone and  this woman is out for vengeance dirty  cops what was the most exciting thing  from seeing the trailer today oh the  most exciting thing was just that it  looks good you just wanted to look good  and that the drama really plates  watching someone take everything from  you they turned you into somebody else  social media is lit up with support for  she's a multiple homicide suspect  not to them she's not